maybe got a little these two bundles of
fur the world's first lion cubs can see
through non-surgical artificial
insemination Isabel and Viktor were born
last week at the U Cotulla Conservation
Center and bio bank in South Africa
Lilly Jacobs is the center's founder and
owner now many people may think that
that what is so special about artificial
insemination for the Lions but Lions are
different and although many have tried
over many years it's never been
successful before weighing in around 3
pounds apiece these Cubs have made a
monumental impact for researchers in
understanding big cat reproductive
systems so these two Cubs represent 18
months of dedicated hard work to
establish a protocol way by not only the
Lions might benefit in the future but
critically endangered cat species of
which there are only very very few in
number list the African lion population
is estimated to have decreased from 1.2
million in 1800 to only 18,000 this year
researchers and conservationists hoped
that the new technique can help bring
some of the big cat populations back to
life well this is one step towards being
able to apply these artificial
reproductive techniques in other species
so this is a very very important step no
one can argue away the value of of what
has been achieved over here